you are looking at a supermodel
no not me my friends here on my left
the naked mole rat so hello and welcome
to the cheeky science show where in this
video
we're going to look at naked mole rats
and why in the world of animal models
the naked mole rats are the supermodels
so once we've looked at why naked mole
rats are supermodels
we'll then try and look at some of the
mechanisms that underpin
why naked mole rats seem to be able to
evade
cancer development and also seem not to
age
but firstly what are naked mole rats
characterized by their wrinkled skin and
large protrading teeth
naked mole rats are rodents that live in
large
subterranean colonies living underground
in east africa
the temperature remains pretty constant
so the naked mole rats have no need for
insulation
and hence why they're called the naked
mole rats as they've lost their fur
but their nudity isn't the reason why
they are supermodels
instead it is because they are beautiful
on the inside
and for their small size they have an
extremely long
lifespan in captivity naked mole rats
have been shown to live
up to 32 years that's eight times longer
than mice of a similar size that can
live at most around four years in
captivity
but that isn't the only reason that
makes naked molerats
supermodels they are also very resistant
to cancer to put this into some
perspective
around 50 to 90 percent of aged mice die
cancer and in humans this number is
lower around 23
indeed different animal species
dramatically differ
in their cancer rates and ages of
disease onset
this is a bit of a paradox
pito's paradox actually the name of this
paradox came from richard pito
who reasoned that the cells in large
bodied long-lived animals
undergo more cell divisions and with
every cell division
carrying a small risk of introducing
mutations and daughter cells
which could lead to cancer development
you may expect
large-bodied long-lived animals to have
a greater risk of cancer than small
short-lived ones
however this isn't always the case as
evidenced by the fact that mice have a
greater cancer rate
than humans now you might be thinking
but naked mole rats fit this trend
for their body size they have a really
low rate of tumor development
however another factor influencing the
risk of cancer
is lifespan there is great evolutionary
pressure to have
effective anti-cancer mechanisms before
reproductive age otherwise the animal
would leave no progeny
after reproductive age then cancer
becomes more frequent
as the animals are no longer subjected
to natural selection
however this just makes pito's paradox
the more complicated
so how come the longest lift rodent the
naked mole rats
not only has extreme anti-cancer
mechanisms
but also has a long lifespan for its
size
what is their secrets well instead i
should say what are their secrets
because multiple mechanisms are involved
in the remarkable cancer resistance
of the naked mole rats and it kind of
makes sense
to be able to live 8 times to 10 times
longer than that of mice
one mechanism would be insufficient now
to understand the mechanisms that
prevent cancer formation
you need to understand how cancer forms
in the first place
and whilst we don't fully understand
this process at the moment
and the variety of different ways that
it can happen cancer formation is simply
a result of uncontrolled
cell division basically a cell just
keeps defining
and dividing and dividing and defining
and dividing and still forms a tumor in
long-lived mammals
like ourselves we have a mechanism
within ourselves
that enter replicative senescence when a
cell divides too many times
this is because the telomeres at the end
of dna
that keep dna intact shorten every time
the cell divides
and so when the cells divided too many
times it induces replicative senescence
as any further divisions would risk the
integrity of the dna structure
so because of this the cell stops
dividing however
naked mole rats don't show replicative
senescence
and instead depend on early acting
anti-cancer mechanisms
so the first cancer assistance mechanism
in the naked mole rats
is early contact inhibition contact
inhibition
is when a cell stops dividing because it
gets too close to other cells
instead the cells form a monolayer in
cancerous cells they overcome this
contact inhibition and starts growing on
top of each other
naked mole rats have two different genes
that are involved in triggering the
early contact inhibition
one of these is p16 and the other is p27
the benefit of having two genes means
that if one of the genes is silenced or
mutated
the other one is still present to induce
the contact inhibition
and this is particularly important
because contact inhibition is frequently
lost in tumors
another cancer resistance mechanism in
naked mole rats
is the presence of a novel protein
product that helps to inhibit the cell
cycle
the gene locus by this novel protein
product is encoded
is already quite complicated and
includes p16 as i've already mentioned
earlier
but this new protein product results
from the fusion
of two genes p16 and p15
that happens during the stage of
transcription in a process referred to
as alternative splicing the protein
product
which is given the name p oat acts as an
inhibitor of the cell cycle
which adds another layer of control to
the naked mole rat cells
but it doesn't end there the naked mole
rats in addition to having these
internal mechanisms within their cells
to induce contact inhibition
they also have external factors that can
also induce contact inhibition
for example naked mole rat cells
secretes
a high molecular mass hyaluronin so
hyaluronine is an extracellular matrix
component
and so human cells can also generate
hyaluronan molecules
but they're six to ten times shorter
than that in naked mole rats
and it seems that these much longer
molecules of hyaluronan
have anti-proliferative
anti-inflammatory and anti-metastatic
properties
for example signaling downstream of
hyaluronian
can activate expression of genes within
the locus that i just mentioned
where p16 resides however the
intermediate steps between hyaluronin
and
the expression of these genes isn't
quite understood yet
so how come naked mole rats can generate
these long molecules of hyaluronin and
we can't
well firstly the gene that generates
hyaluronan
hyaluronan synthase ii catchy name
has a unique sequence that's different
to what we have and that could be the
reason why
the production of hyaluronic is
different secondly
enzymes that degrade hyaluronan have
very low activity in the tissues of
naked mole rats
so these two factors together may be
contributing to this high abundance
of these long chains of hyaluronan that
are present in the naked mole rats
that seem to have these anti-cancer
mechanisms
and we're still not finished naked mole
rat cells are also very sensitive to
loss of tumor suppressors
including my favorite protein p53
when these tumor suppressors are lost
within the naked mole rat cells
they can trigger apoptosis or senescence
stopping a cell in its tracks before it
can even think about forming a tumor
and the crazy thing is we still haven't
finished naked mole rat cells also have
a very low reprogramming efficiency
which has been suggested to mean that
the cells have a very stable epigenome
which can also help contribute to the
tumor resistance
seen in their cells if you're interested
in understanding more details about
these different mechanisms then i
recommend you checking out this nature
review
that also lists even additional
mechanisms found in the naked mole rats
including high fidelity protein
synthesis a more active antioxidant
response pathway
and more active prosthesis through
autophagy and the proteasome
but as mentioned during the beginning of
this video naked mole rats
aren't just supermodels for their
anti-cancer mechanisms
they're also super models for their long
lifespan for their body size
now for certain some of the mechanisms
that i've already mentioned
that have cancer resistance also play a
role in their long
lifespan but these are naked mole rats
that we're talking about
so they have a few more tricks up their
sleeves well
that's if they actually house leaves
anyway
an important pathway in lifespan
extension
in a variety of different model
organisms are nutrient-sensing pathways
this regulation of these
nutrient-sensing pathways
is actually one of the hallmarks of
aging and it's also thought that
variations in these different pathways
in different organisms
may help to explain the 500-fold
difference in maximal lifespan
in different vertebrate species from
0.75 years in african
kilifish to almost 400 years
in the greenland sharks and so naked
molerats are thought to have
adaptive genetic variants within two
genes
that encode proteins involved in these
nutrient signaling pathways
one of which is variations in the gene
sequence for igf-1
and other sequences for the protein rep
which is a regulator of mtor a critical
component
in the nutrient signaling pathways and
so i'm going to give another shout out
to a different review article this time
this one which specifically focuses on
vertebrates differences and lifespan
and in particular i like the way that
they tries to explain nutrient sensing
as being a potential rheostat for the
evolution of longevity in different
species
but going back to the naked mole rats in
addition to effeding cancer
and having a long lifespan for their
size it's also thought that
naked mole rats don't even age the
support for this observation
comes from this relatively recent paper
that showed that unlike all other
mammals
naked mole rats have an age specific
hazard of mortality
that didn't increase with age even at
ages 25 fold past their time of
reproductive maturity
now this is interesting given that i
recently made a video about aging being
the price we pay for cancer protection
but i also agree with this article that
suggests that we shouldn't over
interpret this data
and that older and more mole rats are
needed to validate
this data further but given all the
mechanisms i've discussed in this video
i think it goes without saying the naked
mole rats deserve their title as
supermodels and are very interesting
organisms to study
so i hope you've learned something in
this video and
as always thanks for listening